The Punisher season 1 it's about time I
talk about this right I apologize it's
so late there's a good reason for that
I didn't really want to talk about this
on my channel it's been it was it was
tough something that's happened that
made it really hard to get through this
this show here's a video explaining
everything he went I'm trying to watch
The Punisher
these people have been have been one in
this review my dogs just need a lot of
attention now know what else to say
knowing truth I watched like the first
half of the show and then I really had
to start working on my book and movies
came out every single weekend new
releases it just it got buried but I
finally finished it and let's talk about
it and this review is going to contain
full spoilers for season 1 Jon Bernthal
reprises his role from daredevil season
2 the man who lost his family Frank
Castle he's on a revenge path looking
for the men responsible which also
uncovers a bit of a conspiracy that was
hidden for a long time that traces back
to his roots leading him to some very
horrible discoveries now let's talk
about the good first Jon Bernthal is
incredible in this role he seems almost
built for it even in scenes that are
supposed to be more lighthearted it
seems like he's two seconds away from
having a complete breakdown and that's
because this is a fantastic actor every
chance he gets
he lets this character explode with rage
and a lot of hidden depth
he's so terrific in this role and he
seems built for it but this season did
something I didn't expect there's a lot
of down time he meets a guy named Mike
Rowe who has been dead supposedly for a
year he's hiding himself in a basement
somewhere while filming his family who
still thinks he's dead and they work
together to try to take down some of the
men responsible for both of their
positions and in so doing the series can
be a little slow at times
first half of this show suffers from
stretching one tiny plot very thin we
have a hero who's on a revenge path
that's only so much having this
characters woes on display in not only
daredevil season 2 but his own show
you're gonna have to stretch that a
little farther than my family died and
I'm mad because there's only so much you
can get out of that and this season does
do a pretty good job of giving him
compelling reasons to be relevant but
the first half of the show does take a
while to get going because you're
watching a show called The Punisher and
while the pilot episode does have some
very satisfying moments and sets up this
guy pretty well the next few episodes
take on a lot of baggage with the
character named Madani and all of her
backstory and her partner and then you
have micros family and micro himself and
you have the corruption that's going on
that's also connected to Frank's past
and his military life and all this comes
to a head towards the last half of the
season when it really starts to pick up
but that first half is a bit slow and I
was kind of waiting for the Punisher to
punish some people towards the end of
the season I got a lot of great moments
I would say episode 12 is probably my
favorite episode it's extremely violent
but getting to that point did take a
while it feels like one very simple
story has been stretched very thin and
while I was riveted pretty much every
single second Jon Bernthal was on screen
they go away from him so much to focus
on some of his old teammates his former
comrades and then all this stuff going
on with homeland security that kind of
bogs down the show it gives it a more
realistic and gritty sense to it but it
did take a while to get going that's my
biggest issue with season 1 by far one
of the most brutal and effective and
searing elements of this season is the
examination of what war can do to
someone one of my favorite characters in
the season was Curtis he's a guy who
works now trying to console various army
vets he lost a leg himself and now it's
his duty he feels to try to support
other men and women who are dealing with
similar issues who feel like they have a
lot of
shellshock and PTSD and he was on my
favorite characters in the show but
there's also another character portrayed
by Daniel Weber who was in 11/22/63 the
Stephen King drama he plays a character
named Lewis who eventually turns into a
legitimate full-blown terrorist and this
character creates an interesting
contrast with Frank Castle because many
people view Frank Castle as a terrorist
as well in fact some people who even
enjoy this show think the Punisher is
legitimately a terrorist but I like how
they have someone who is so damaged by
war in Lewis's character who goes out
and makes bombs and plants them around
because he's trying to send a message a
legitimate homegrown terrorist and then
he have somebody who is out for revenge
killing anybody who gets in his way who
is connected to these horrible acts but
it's not just that he's killing them
this show does not pull any punches in
the message that this guy is kind of
deranged when it comes to violence and
death and murder when when shit starts
going down and bullets start flying when
he gets a hold of a knife or really any
any object that he can use you see a
psychopath emerge and that contrast
between someone who spends his time at
home making bombs spreading them around
the city and cowardly acts of violence
and then someone like Frank Castle who
has specific targets that he's trying to
eliminate because he feels that he won't
be right until he does that both men are
in a terribly bad place both men are
using violence to solve problems but the
difference is one is a coward one is
aiming at innocent people another isn't
and he is his targets are guilty people
and so some people who know him respect
him because he's doing things that the
cops just won't do by using vigilante
justice to solve problems now we've seen
this explored in films and in TV shows
before most recently in death wish Eli
Roth's remake and sometimes the message
is muddled by this we have to make an
entertaining action movie sense that
allow directors like Eli Roth take when
they make a film
or a show about a vigilante what's great
about this season is that it never shied
away from the fact that Frank Castle is
incredibly damaged and he will never
recover fully from this he's a broken
man
and he's never going to get out of that
and it presents a lot of very painful
scenarios in which Frank Castle has to
continue to relive the knowledge that
he's done really as a person he can
never have a normal life again
and he knows that it's one of the things
that sets this apart from most vigilante
justice films or TV shows this lead
character knows that he's in the wrong
he knows he's not a good person he's
just got a little bit of empathy for him
and he understands the difference
between guilt and innocence he's not
just going out looking to kill folks
he just has specific targets that he
knows should not be walking amongst the
rest of humanity which is something that
makes this show better than most
vigilante justice shows her movies now I
don't want to diminish the character of
Madani played by Amber Rose Reva
because after her partner gets killed
her character becomes infinitely more
interesting and we can finally just
focus on her it was really just the
dynamic between her and her partner that
I didn't really appreciate as soon as he
was out of the picture it gave her
something to be truly angry about and
they manipulated things with her in the
character Billy Russo who ends up being
a complete asshole really well and that
made her character so much more
interesting when we could just focus on
her and she kind of went rogue and did
her own thing and I really loved Amber
Rose Reva in this series she's so good
really amazing casting there and I hope
to see her and other things the show has
a really good way of making you hate the
villains and they knew they had to do
that because we have a hero who grabs
guns and kills everybody so there has to
be a reason where we can be like yep
those people should not be here right
now they should either be behind bars or
Six Feet Under and in creating those
terrible characters you can understand
why Frank hates these people so much and
why they should probably not be in the
picture anymore and so you feel like you
can have some sympathy for him all in
all the Punisher Season one did have a
slow start and I feel like if a lot of
critics just watched the first half of
this season they'd be like
not so much but if you stick with it
long enough it gets a lot better still I
wish it was exciting from the beginning
it could have been a lot more from the
very beginning it takes a while for the
Punisher to start punishing things but
once he does and the show revs up its
gears with its characters it gets more
interesting I'm gonna give the Punisher
season 1 of B - guys thank you so much
as always for watching I'm gonna be
reviewing Jessica Jones season 2 very
soon I haven't even started yet I wanted
to finish the Punisher you guys are the
best and as always if you liked this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
[Music]